or the other
um saving money I don't
necessarily think is is one of them I
think I think that's just like a
personality type in an individual thing
there's people who are just bad with
money yeah they're Reckless there's
dudes who go out and they Gamble and
they spend and they buy trainers they
just buy they buy nonsense and there's
women who go out and blow their money on
nonsense
I don't think it's that gendered but I
think I think perhaps a more important
point is that if you have got that
person you've got uh you know your wife
your husband whatever it's supposed to
be a partnership right it's it's
supposed to be a partnership and
different individuals can work out how
that works if it's like okay look babe
you're really good with money I'm kind
of Reckless with spending it you handle
the saving or investing or whatever or
it could be you know what I'm the one
who knows how to invest and save and
whatever like I'll handle the majority
of that
as long as it works as a unit and you
know I I think and I understand people
wanting to be independent independent
independent but I think that mindset can
be quite dangerous for relationships
when you're not willing to entrust the
other person it's it's a partnership
right you can entrust that person and
say you know what you're good at
handling that you handle this I'm good
at handling this I've got this you don't
need to worry about it you don't need to
be working in isolation all the time I
think it's good for every adult male
female whatever I think it's good for
every adult to be competent to have
General competencies so that if you're
single or if something goes wrong or
whatever you're not totally you're not
you're not useless right I think
everybody should know how to cook basic
food right I don't think it's just you
know a woman should know how to cook a
mansion I think if you are a grown man
and you're 35 years old and you don't
know how to boil rice or cook a basic
meal I'm like bro like come on man yeah
right you should know how to load load
you should know how to load load the
washing you should know how to do some
some basic tests everyone should know
how to make money right least on a basic
level some people are going to be better
at it than others but you should have a
skill you should have a couple
monetizable skills that okay even if
you're not right like I'm I'm not
married yet but when I am like my wife
is absolutely not going to have to work
right not a paid job per se right she's
going to be doing some type of work she
can have a typical job if she wants to
she won't have to
um but I would like to marry someone who
I know is is competent so that God
forbid something happens to me or
whatever like my kids are not gonna
starve and be destitute
um but yeah I just think it's about
finding that finding that balance and
that those complementary aspects and I
think that when people partner up and
and do that well then the whole the
whole thing just functions and it's good
and you can just trust I agree with you
and then you're not worried about this
is this is my money that's your money
and then it gets kind of weird and
you're keeping score yeah
I think we live in an age now where men
don't want to accept that women are
competent and because back in the days
it worked you go to work I cook I clean
I take care of the kids but now women
are working so don't come home and tell
me to cook and clean because we've just
come from the same [ __ ] well well I
think I think I think you'll just the
truth is you'll have to find uh
you know a man who is
who who accepts that right but the the
problem is the type of man who will
fully accept what you just said there I
imagine is not the type of man you'd be
attracted to
him you see what I mean so I think I
think that's one of the conflicts where
it's like there's a lot of bums that are
okay they're totally fine yeah like
there's a they like it yes guys you
could date a bum but that's the like
that's the message we keep passing on to
men that as soon as your Alpha and
you're confident you have to see a woman
as less than you or you know
that's not abortionate no that's that's
the message we keep passing on you can
be strong okay okay I need you I need
you I need you I'm just gonna I'm gonna
cut you yeah who who says that no you
said the message we're passing on him
who says that no but saying things like
well no like let me say answer your
question so e literally just said I
imagine a man that's okay with that
you're not going to be attracted to
right because because he's not going to
be in his masculine energy yeah a
masculine man
would not is is not going to be drawn
to that
so that's the problem okay I'm attracted
to you I'm just I'm saying no you can
you can be how you want I'm not I'm not
telling you what to do or how to behave
or whatever I'm just telling you real
talk as a man
um you know you can you can have a
certain attitude or a belief system or
whatever I'm just saying a guy who like
there there are guys who would just be
like yeah cool like you know either that
whatever but the type those those type
of guys tend to be more
you know we crame not so much in their
masculine energy not particularly
ambitious and so on like why would why
would a guy that makes a lot of money go
to his girl for financial decisions yeah
like like why would he do that when he
could just not when there's a million he
has a lot of money as well but again
like but your money doesn't matter to a
guy it's like nothing it's like it's
like like imagine when a guy tells us oh
I have a cool shoe collection you're
like ah cool but you don't really care
it's the same thing and so you can come
in and like say oh I have money too he
says okay don't care
we care about money let's not cap women
come on like you're not you're not
trying to date a bomb
like but but a guy will
like a guy will see a girl at Tesco and
say it like if she's hot enough cool
yeah yes and similarly she could be the
freaking CEO of a company but if she's
not hot and yeah that's nice of the
feminine traits then you're not
interested are you are you lining up to
date Oprah no no
she's not even been lining up today
Oprah it's beautiful
the truth is I look and we all know this
men and women are not attracted to the
identical same things yeah we I think we
know this and there's no amount of
social engineering that is going to that
that's going to just change that right
I'm sure look every short guy would love
to somehow manipulate society and
culture and biology to make women more
attracted to very short guys right but
it's just it's not reality so if you're
a short dude you just have to accept
look this is my height I can't change
this right but there's lots of other
things that I can do there's ways that I
can improve myself and compensate and
still be an attractive and and confident
and competent man but you just have to
accept that given reality as a male
there are certain things that men are
generally attracted to in women and some
people may not like that it may trigger
them right here's one that you can't
change age
that's not that's not changeable right
but so if a man says that a man if a man
if a woman says that she prefers taller
guys which literally every woman does no
one takes offense to that if a man says
if a guy is 35 and he's like yeah I
prefer dating younger women oh my God
right he's suddenly some despite the
fact that every man all throughout
history whatever go ahead yeah can I
just say something yeah sorry finish
what you were saying and then I can I've
pretty much made my point so go ahead
okay
is sort of going off of the bat of that
as well is that actually when you are
and this is only something that I've
come to like realize in the last
I'd say sort of six months that actually
being older like no matter how much I've
tried to run away from it try to change
it looks wise all those things would be
like this is bad you know why why can't
I just be 26 again 25 again all that is
actually it's actually really powerful
being in that space and feeling that way
because that way I can in a female way
keep leveling up keep you know keep on
top of trying to stay in shape trying to
stay healthy
um keeping my Womanhood as much as I
possibly can you know I know you
probably can't imagine this right now
because you're 26. but when you're 10 12
years older than that it takes a lot of
work to
I don't know to still feel useful but
still to to still feel youthful and
useful in a way to
um my partner to blend into society
because you when you're when you're 26
you kind of get a lot more on your plate
in your life than you do when you're 36
as a woman as a woman they're not as a
guy but as a woman things completely
change like when you were 22 I bet
things were very different to what they
are now at 26 there's all those jumps so
I don't know if you you've had that
realization but it will help you to like
keep leveling up as a woman like guys
they focus on Fitness and money and
whatever it may be to level themselves
up but for me you know yes it's
exhausting yes it costs money but it
keeps me healthier and in a better
balance as a Woman Within Myself even
though I might be doing it more for my
boyfriend is actually rubbing off on me
but shouldn't that be a human being
thing because I want to look good yeah I
do but I expect my man to look good and
this is why I won't go for a sugar daddy
I don't care how much money you have I'm
not attracted to you a lot of women
would because like you said anxiety
it just over it's beautiful
that's not a sugar daddy
if that is my whole husband what you
mean who's that did you sober yeah he's
your type
yourself wow
he's probably better known in the UK as
well to be fair oh okay yeah he's better
known in the UK I heard a lot of
Americans yeah he's known in the US but
I think he's better now I think he's
better known here yeah I think he's
better known here we black people know
what what we know we think everyone else
knows it but you should know who Ides
please do you you'll know him if you saw
him okay
but my point is I do think like we keep
thinking it's this idea we keep passing
this message that it's okay for a man to
just have money no it's not go to the
gym and work out the money ain't gonna
say I don't think I think that's a
strong man I don't think anyone is
saying men just need to have money yeah
but the point we were just talking about
the point is that it's a factor it's a
factor for men it's a
um
yeah yeah my point is if you ask a man
what five things are you looking for in
a woman money is almost never gonna come
up job is almost never going to come up
qualifications are almost never going to
come up it's not true the other way
around to be fair not nowadays because
men be having sugar mummies nowadays
it's true yes
what maybe one for every 20 girls that
do I mean it's but it's happening like
have you seen how many men on early fans
now yeah but that's for gay men no
straight men their customers
we actually did have an only fans guy on
the show that like his primary now
they're a girl they're a woman yeah yeah
no no but I'll tell you what it is
though they don't make that much money
no he doesn't he doesn't make beer as
much
the ones who are earning a lot their
audiences game yeah no no but the pro
the reason for that is because it's not
a market for women it's a market for men
pay for sex yes that's just the way it
is yeah exactly so that's the only
reason you think if men were making a
lot of money you think they won't join
only fans really no I've never seen it
I'm just saying that their audiences
came in because of male sexuality is
different from female sexual same reason
that male prostitutes you know there our
audience is their clientele are gay men
like it's men who buy sex as you said
yeah it's men who buy sex it's men who
buy porn and so on and so forth it's
very very small percentage of women who
are the market for that and it's always
been that way across societies across
countries across cultures male sexuality
is is different from female sexuality
and that's fine that's good that's not a
bad thing why do you guys think that
women are becoming masculine nowadays
because men are becoming feminine yeah
no honestly you're you know it's I put a
lot of blame on on men for a lot of the
stuff that you know even even men men
complain about right
um really I feel like it started with
the women
look some of it does but men men have
created certain conditions on a big
level right right okay look how many
people how many people are raised by how
many millions of people in Western
Society now are raised by single mothers
right but why
oftentimes because men are not playing
their role that exists that's that's a
big thing but then you've oh you've got
an imbalance right you've got both men
and women are being raised primarily
just by women and the masculine role is
missing and that manifests differently
for both for for boys and girls as they
grow into as they grow into men and
women and as a woman it's naturally if
if a man is not present there you've now
got to play both you've got to play both
roles so
what no you don't well I mean I was a
single parent that's that's this is a
lie that the women say this okay what I
mean is you you are
it's a it's a typically raising a child
is a two-person job you have the father
you have the mother and in the absence
of a father whether that is through
death or through absence or through
whatever the reason
what I mean what I mean by play both
roles is you've got one person
doing a two-person
we're in control of birth so we pick who
gets born so it's our own fault like
that's why I say it starts with the
women I don't because and like and on
top of that like it's the development of
birth control I feel like the
development yeah
you're right I would say if I was to put
it on men I would say it's because men
did all that men men as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible